[Music]
hey what's up Wolfgang today there seems
to be a video of the filming of a
vendor's fort that has resurfaced
I say resurfaced because I've seen this
before I'm sure some of you have as well
but when it was up before it was only up
for a very brief period of time before
it was taken down and I didn't really
have any time to dissect it or grab it
for a video now honestly there's not too
much here anything you could say about
this video is going to be pure
speculation for the most part especially
because we still have the leaked photos
of this scene that is being filmed right
here we've had them for a while so
things like Captain America is wearing
his old uniform and they're in New York
right in the middle of the battle and
the first Avengers movie and that means
they clearly time traveled and not to
mention Scott Lang is there and from
this video it appears that his only
purpose in being here with Captain
America and Iron Man is simply to get
them there they clearly travel in the
past due to ant man's quantum realm
technology that I'm sure we'll see
develop even more in ant-man of the wasp
so again we know these things but there
still is a little bit that this video
can tell us let's start with the first
part of this clip if you look at the top
of the screen you'll see Tony Stark
coming in he'll be walking towards
Captain America the Hulk and ant-man and
he's carrying a bag now there's really
no way of knowing what's in the bag
again it's gonna be pure speculation it
could be anything it could be extra
armor for his suit even though he's
wearing and otech right now it could be
something that ant-man and hate Pym
created together it could be something
that Tony Stark created we really don't
know now what I think would just be
insanely cool is that if inside the bag
he had his own Infinity Gauntlet that he
made for the mind stone that they're
trying to get more on that in just a
second when Tony walks in he seems to be
pointing at something and what I think
it is is stark tower and what I get from
this is that Tony is clearly in charge
and it makes sense because I actually
think that the
in America in the scene is that present
time Captain America and not from the
future
so Tony walks up to Captain America and
it appears that he shows him what's in
the bag but captain doesn't seem to make
a big deal about it at all so maybe it's
just some stark device or you know some
armor for Iron Man or something but it
clearly didn't faze captain at all we
can see Tony Stark talking to Captain
America and then Captain America kind of
steps out in the middle of the mall he
looks around then it looks like he looks
at Scott Lang and then he kind of shrugs
his shoulders his arms kind of flail out
a little bit
as to what they're saying again it's
gonna be pure speculation there's no way
that we can really know but what I think
is actually going on here and again this
is just my personal opinion I think that
they're probably at the bottom of stark
tower I think that only Iron Man Ant Man
and the Hulk went back in time I think
that the Captain America that's in this
scene is in the present time that
they're in and what I think is going on
here is that Tony Stark is telling
Captain America hey that sceptre that
staff that Loki has what's power in it
is actually what's called an infinity
stone in particular the mine stone and I
think that they're going to try and get
it because I think they might be
following the theory that Tony Stark is
going to attempt to make his own
Infinity Gauntlet and in doing so we'll
try to collect all the stones and
reverse everything that Thanos did and
why I think captain is shrugging his
shoulders here is because he really
doesn't know what an infinity stone is
yet he doesn't know what the mine Sun is
and not to mention ant-man's there he
probably cracked some weird joke that
captain didn't really get and that's the
end of the clip again we don't really
know what's going on here it's gonna be
pure speculation up to this point until
we get more information about what
Avengers 4 is truly going to be about
but I wanted to get the footage out so
at least you all could see it if you
haven't and it's fun to make our own
theories about it I am genuinely curious
about what you all think is in that bag
and what you think is happening in these
scenes so let me know your thoughts in
the comments below be sure to hit that
like button before you leave and please
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Avengers 4 Marvel DC and all
things superhero and we're going to be
announcing the start of another give
'we coming up in the next handful of
days so stay tuned thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
you